[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Conan O'Brien here is my video blog
here's what's going on the new trailer
for Iron Man 3 just came out it's pretty
awesome
the thing I don't get is if fire man is
already in the Avengers why would he
ever fight anyone by himself right I
mean he's got the Hulk's phone number
like call the Hulk that's an idea I had
Dennis Rodman went to North Korea last
week and he met with Kim jong-un to
picture it now they're best friends
so this first segments called retired
NBA players visiting with foreign
dictators retired NBA players visit Lee
with foreign dictators here's my mood
Ahmadinejad and Scottie Pippen right
here here's Syria's Assad with Larry
Bird pretty nice and here's Vladimir
Putin with Muggsy Bogues that was
retired NBA players visiting with
foreign dictators retired NBA players
visiting with foreign dictators okay
this next segments called crow bop grow
up this is where I take today's biggest
pop hits and I asked Russell Crowe who
was in lame is to sing them here's
Russell singing one Direction's you
don't know you're beautiful beautiful
beautiful furious singing Taylor Swift's
I knew you were trouble here he is
singing thrift shop from Macklemore and
Ryan Lewis walk into the club like what
up I got a freak
that was crow Bob grow up any you kids
out there feeling awkward feeling that
you're like the dorkiest kid in the
world this video is gonna make you feel
a lot better
[Music]
you're welcome this last segments called
animals with emotions animals with
emotions okay this is an angry cats cats
angry because he found marijuana in his
daughter's dresser this lizard just saw
Kate Upton on the cover of Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit Issue this otter
just found out that IKEA puts horse meat
in its meatballs this elephant seal just
saw paul blart mall cop for like the
fifth time this gecko was just caught
pleasuring himself in public his cat was
also found pleasuring himself but he's
like hey deal with a
[Applause]